[Musique]
les shadoks élégie bis qui vivent sur
des planètes différentes ont décidé
d'aller vivre sur la terre les jib y
étaient de petits animaux très gentil
avec un petit chapeau sur la tête pour
pouvoir se dire bonjour et il était très
très intelligente pour aller et sur la
terre ils ont construit une fusée elle
fonctionne grâce à un combustible
superpuissant le cosmo gaulle 999
dès qu'il y aura suffisamment de
combustible l'affairé jbe pourra partir
mais quel est ce combustible miracle
d'où les jbe l'extrait t-il comme vous
le savez la planète jbe etp l'acte dès
que l'on creuse un trou retombe de
l'autre côté les jbe ne peuvent donc
rien extraire du sous sol sans cela leur
planète serait une vraie passoire cjd
extrait le cosmologue en 1999 de
l'atmosphère
celle ci est recueillie dans d'énormes
jantes aulnoye atmosphère et puis pompée
dans des pompes à atmosphère par un
procédé secrets et les jbe on extrait le
cosmo gun brut di cosmo goal de première
pression qui une fois raffiné concentré
et enrichit donne le fameux cosmo gun
999 qui propulsera la fusée jbe mais les
jbe pourront-ils produits acides de
cosmo gaulle pour arriver sur la terre
avant les affreux shadow
[Musique]